[Musik]
motto wir jetzt mal kurz berichtet roman
tobi und die jungs könnten zur
tankstelle selber mischen macht aber
mehr bock in die tanks passen neun liter
in die anderen sieben also achten in dem
banalen tagen die verwandten irgendwo in
der oberlausitz zwischen hoyerswerda und
bautzen wo genau soll keine rolle
spielen damit ihnen nach diesem film
niemand die mopeds cloud 40 50 jahre alt
sind ihre simson schätze der von nico
sogar 60 20 zimmern und dann läuft's und
weise seit damals und das habe ich jetzt
schon fünf jahre das habe ich von meinem
onkel bekommen
dieses von 1960
alles original und für kurt der nächste
kabelbinder nie weit
man muss ja nur was kaputt ist nicht
erwischen lassen man kann ja mal
versuchen das zu reparieren
die moped brille soll noch viele jahre
halten
das löten ihnen dass wir so richtig
funktionieren
das war ein bissel oft proben müssen
unsere geschichte vor der ausfahrt
sonntagnachmittag getriebe stellschraube
festziehen simple noch sicherheitscheck
tobi will mit seiner s 50 schließlich
nicht liegen bleiben
da wird viel locker und da ist das so
das größte problem und wenn den fersen
und eben das ding galaxie schalten da
stehst da an der straße und koks und
willst
sie fahren durch das land ihrer eltern
aber in einem anderen staat ein bisschen
ddr haben sie geerbt
mindestens das was sie unterm hintern
haben sie sind die generationen simson
auf die welt gekommen rund zehn jahre
nach mauerfall und deutscher einheit die
millennials des ländlichen osten sind zu
hause auf dörfern und einsamen straßen
moped gangs wie die von tobi geben gas
von usedom bis eisenach auf maschinen
mit originallack im zweitakt und stolz
auf ihre herkunft
wie ticken diese jungs vom land worauf
kommt es an für sie im leben was lieben
sie und was regt sie auf und warum wirkt
die wände so lange nach ihre werkstatt
haben sich die jungs erst vor ein paar
wochen eingerichtet zum schrauben feiern
zusammen sein mit sich und ihren
maschinen dürfte hier eigentlich eine e
schwalbe rein
zu ddr zeiten gab so nimmt die
sonnenbrille ab
wir sind die schwalbe runter es 50 drauf
die hier wollen sie als nächstes
aufbauen kurz hat sie von seinem onkel
bekommen noch mit ein paar macken
wir sind jetzt auf ihrer suche und
denken den fehler jetzt gleich beheben
zu können
also dann den kfz mechaniker ist keiner
hier basteln und schrauben blut hobby
trotzdem können sie jede schraube gute
leitung könnte man auch geld verdienen
mit sensoren reparieren
damit kannst du dir vielleicht die
scheibe brot kaufen aber den familien
ich will mal sicherungskasten
die jungs arbeiten oder studieren alle
nicht weit von zu hause kennen sich seit
sie kinder sind in der werkstatt findet
jeder sein glück
was macht mehr spaß fahren oder
schrauben ja da kannst du ausleben und
komplett frei also wirklich komplett
frei entfalten dass das fahren ist dass
das die typischen auf der ganzen
angelegenheit aber wenn du halt schraub
schraub schraub zwei monate über tage
und dann ein fertiges endprodukt sie ist
dann geht er denn neben erinnert als 5
erst simson gleich glück und freiheit
vor allem auf dem land dass man die
mopeds im osten mit ihren 60 km/h schon
ab 15 fahren darf geregelte der
beitrittsvertrag roller sind im osten
deshalb auch die roller fahren 45 km/h
jetzt jetzt steigst du aufs moped und
460 km h mit dem gleichen führerschein
du bist fünften und kann's kann es
selber auf der straße rum erhält diese
selbständigkeit dass man von dorf zu
dorf fahren kann ohne sie zu fragen und
wir sind ja schon ein bisschen älter
bewusst ist dass raus ja mal ein auto
aber wie gesagt wir fahren trotzdem alle
noch durch die gegend einfach was uns
spaß macht gibt es auch jugendliche ohne
so ein teil oder fährt hier jeder sinne
eigentlich jeder also eine jugendlichen
hat eigentlich hat jeder jugendliche in
moped doch wenn du hier was anderes fest
wenn die mit dem roller rumpf erst dann
kriegst auch die neuzeit befragung dann
einfach sagen das ist schwul ist ja da
wirst du erstmal spruch bestimmt selbst
selbst mädchen mit dem roller die wo das
schiff angeguckt die kann sonst gut
aussehen die wurde ja jetzt doch mal
eine sitzbank
da ist die original luftpumpe und mit
drin
schluss original werkzeug und
ersatzteile volltreffer das ist halt
sehr selten das halt in herz kosten
wirklich so vollständig ist wieder hier
ist mit bob werkzeug für eine erste
hilfe angriff und die birnen für blinker
rücklicht und sonne mit hamann transfers
bis nach leningrad
es ist halt so robust es ist robust und
macht sie alle süchtig wenn du anfängst
da könnte er ihn ja fragen wir haben
jetzt hier immer komplett neu aufgebaut
verstecken 56 scheine das auto wohl und
ich habe fürs moped mehr investiert wie
für das momentan das ist eine wertanlage
kann man sich die vorstösse ich das auto
natürlich weil einfach der wert der
dasteht zu schade somit zu fahren das
ist für treffen zu müssen
angucken und streicheln und lächelnd im
bett liegen und sich freuen was man
unten im keller oder einem schuppen oder
in der werkstatt stehen hat auf der
cloud wird erschossen und das ist kein
spaß
draußen geht ein video rum von der party
letzten abend in der werkstatt und noch
was und wer von schlager bis früh um
fünf und die nachbarn befragen nachbarn
zur disco in hoyerswerda oder bautzen
oft schade ums geld findet man zahlt ja
mittlerweile
[Musik]
eric studiert lehramt mathe physik kurth
ist gelernter fischwirt jan
industriemechaniker tobi arbeitet bei
einer versicherung wo man lernt
elektriker das ding baggert braunkohle
und florian ist in der immobilienbranche
ost jungs die durch ihre jobs immer mal
wieder kurz in den westen kommen und
meistens schnell wieder zurück wollen
den stempel abgehängte osten finden sie
beleidigend wie die rub gegen das ein
bisschen zurückgeblieben sind und das
ist halt nun mal so dass du 10 15
kilometer bis im nächsten supermarkt vor
musste dann ist es so so sind wir
aufgewachsen im westen ist es so da
löste wahrscheinlich muss die straße
runter kommt daniel etter und das ich
will das auch nicht anders haben warum
ich wir brauchen das nicht sagte mal wir
haben wir haben eine lebensfreude das
ist daran sind uns geht es gut wir sind
gesund wir sind in der natur draußen
wir können ja definitiv mehr machen als
die im westen weil wir hier gehen die
spießigen nachbarn haben gepflegte
klischees kennen sie auch über sich die
im taxi neulich in hamburg wir haben
gesagt wir kommen aus sachsen landkreis
bautzen und da war natürlich das erste
was ihm einfällt naja das braun und afg
und zurückgeblieben
und so weiter und so fort das ist für
mich so was was mir weh tut weil auf der
einen seite wollen wir hier in
deutschland seien aber auf der anderen
seite zumal hier immer nur symbolisch
die mauer in berlin sehen und das kotzt
mich halt extrem an
ja das ist ja das was wiedergegeben wird
dass die ja denken die sachsen diesen
oder allgemeinen die im osten im tiefen
osten die sind alle wir haben alle ein
weg das ist ja das ist ja auch genau das
thema
in ihrer welt kennt jeder jeden größer
und jeder jeder und es gelten ihre
regeln
sie lieben ihre heimat und wollen nicht
dass sie sich verändert vor ein paar
jahren tat sie das zumindest in den
städten
dort treffen sie beim feiern nun auf
gleichaltrige aus syrien und afghanistan
ich will auch nicht da himmel die bude
aufmachen da fliegen mir die
handgranaten entgegen da hätte ich okay
bock dann würde ich auch sofort weg hier
wo dann hast du aber immer das problem
verhalten also aktion reaktion ja und
gerade so auf party oder so da werden
die wahl von hinten am arsch angegriffen
natürlich wir haben wir schon wieder die
flammen und das sind halt so die kleinen
sachen aber die hast du auch wenn jetzt
hier in typ einfach hingeht der von hier
kommt und dem mädel mal kurz beide hände
an po legt dann drehst du oft frei
bestimmt wird es auch heute wieder spät
wenn tobi kurz und die gängen in ihrer
werkstatt an mopeds schrauben irgendwo
in der oberlausitz ganz weit weg vom
westen